PROFESSOR: So our example
is a well-known one.
But it's important
to understand it.
And it's a good example.
It's a familiar one.
It's the hydrogen
molecule ionized.
And we spoke a little
about it last time.
So let's do that now.
So H2 plus, hydrogen ion.
So what is this system?
Well, it is two protons
sharing one electron.
That's basically it.
It's the fact that if you
have a hydrogen atom--
this is hydrogen-- you
could bring another proton
and form a bound state.
That's an important thing
in order to think about it--
you see, you can ask
what is the bound state
energy of your system?
It's the energy you need
to dissociate your system.
But this system, if
you have two protons--
proton, proton--
and one electron,
it can be dissociated
in many ways.
It can be dissociated by
just totally separating
it and destroying it.
But it can be
dissociated or liberated
by just removing the proton.
So this is already
a bound state.
So if you think of
energies, you have
the bound state the energy of
hydrogen here, hydrogen itself,
and the H2 ion--
H2 plus-- must be lower
because you could imagine
taking the proton out and
somehow this system is
a configuration in which
this proton is captured here.
So you should get lower energy
than the hydrogen atom energy.
So that's the hydrogen ion.
And that should be
still more energy
than if you bring
another electron, which
is the H2 molecule.
You bring another electron.
This should bind this
and the other electron
and lower its energy even more.
So how does one solve
for this hydrogen ion?
Well, as we discussed, you first
solve for the electronic wave
function when the protons
are separated at distance r.
So we said fix the lattice.
So here it is.
The lattice is fixed.
It's a separation
capital R. And now
I'm supposed to find the
electron wave function.
Easy?
No.
It already is hard.
We spent several lectures--
you've been studying this three
times already, maybe, in quantum
mechanics, the hydrogen atom,
one proton, one electron.
To protons, one
electron is much harder.
I don't think there's a simple
analytical way to solve it.
So already at this step we
have trouble solving it.
What is the electron,
Hamiltonian in this case?
The electron Hamiltonian
is just one Laplacian here
minus h squared over 2m
for the electron variable,
and then the potential
that is the interactions
of the electron
with the two nuclei.
So if we call this distance
r1 and this distance r2,
that is the whole
electron Hamiltonian.
Now, don't think of
r1 and r2 as you have
two variables, two positions.
No, there is just one position.
The dynamical variables
for this electron, this p
and r for this electron--
r is the position
of the electron.
It happens to be that
r is equal to r1.
And if you know--
so r1 is really
the length of r, the
position of the electron.
And r2 is the
length of capital R,
if we wish, all the
way here, minus r.
r is the vector here, as well.
So there is r1 and
r2, but it's not
two electrons or two variables.
It's just two distances that
depend on the single position
of the electron.
And this is the momentum
operator of the electron.
OK, so you can't solve this.
That's life.
It can't be solved.
But we can do something and we
can do something variational.
We can try to find some
kind of approximation
for the state of
electrons and use that.
So there is an
[INAUDIBLE] that you
could try, a variational
wave function,
for even the electron.
You see, in our argument
in this lecture,
we did the variation
and approximation
for the nuclear degrees of
freedom or for that thing.
But even for the electron wave
function, I can't solve them.
So I have to do a
variational method.
Now, these variational
methods have
become extremely sophisticated.
People do this with a
series of Eigenfunctions
and find answers that converge
with 15 digits accuracy.
It's just unbelievable what
people can do by now with this.
It's a very nice
and developed field.
But we'll do a
baby version of it.
So this baby version
is going to stay.
My wave function
for the electron
as a function of position and
as a function of the separation
is going to be simple.
It's going to be a sum of
ground state wave functions.
It's going to be a number--
a, that's just a number--
times the ground
state wave function
based on the first proton
plus the ground state wave
function based on
the second proton.
So these psis, or psi0 of r is
the ground state wave function
of hydrogen pi a 0 cubed
e to the minus r over a0.
This is called-- people
have given it a name,
even though it's--
you would say it's not that
original to put some wave
function like that.
This is a simple approximation.
And the technique is
called LCAO technique.
And this calls for Linear
Combination of Atomic Orbitals.
A big name for a
rather simple thing.
It has some nice things
about this wave function.
This system is invariant.
This molecule is invariant.
And they're taking a reflection
around this thing changing
the first proton and
the second proton.
So that's the symmetry
of your Hamiltonian.
And it's the symmetry
of [INAUDIBLE]
with the Hamiltonian.
So you can demand that your wave
functions have that symmetry.
And this is nice here because
if you change r1 and r2,
the wave function is invariant.
So that's a very nice thing
about this wave function.
It shows-- you see, you can
put in the variational method
anything and it will still
give you some answer.
But if you put something
that mimics the real wave
functions and the real wave
function of this system
is going to have a symmetry
under the exchange of the two
protons.
They're identical.
So this lattice that you've
created has a symmetry.
So the electron configuration
has to respect that symmetry.
So that's very nice.
Now, this is electronic
wave function.
So I ask you, is this
wave function better
where the protons are far
away or when the protons
are very close to each other?
Give you a minute
to think about it.
When is this approximation
or this wave function better?
If the distance
between the protons
is very little or the
distance between the protons
is very large?
You're right in that when
the two things collapse,
this looks like a
true wave function
because this is a
solution when there's
a single nucleus and
a single electron.
But this is the
solution for hydrogen.
And it gives you the
ground state of hydrogen.
But when the two
protons collapse,
it has become helium nucleus.
It has two protons.
So it doesn't have
the right decay rate.
It doesn't have the
right Born radius.
On the other hand,
when they're far apart,
it does have the right thing.
So this is very good.
It's excellent when the
things are far away.
But it's not great when
they're close together.
So here you go.
You have to normalize
this wave function.
Even that takes some effort.
It turns out that the value
of a for normalization--
the value of a is 1 over
2 1 plus a constant i.
And that constant i is
e to the minus capital
R over a not times 1 plus
r over a not plus 1/3
of r over a not squared.
Wow, so very funny.
It's not so easy to even
calculate the normalization
of this thing.
But that's the normalization.
And then recall that
what we have to do
is just put the electronic
Hamiltonian inside this wave
function, this phi of r.
And this is going to
give us an energy which
is approximately the electronic
energy as a function of r.
So you have to evaluate
the Hamiltonian--
I'm sorry, that
Hamiltonian there--
should have a square here.
And now we evaluate this.
We have to go even
more into gross
and get what is the
potential energy contributed
by the electronic cloud.
So here is the
function that you get.
So our plot here I'll call--
this calls for a
variable x, which
is going to be the
separation divided by a not.
This is the separation between
the protons divided by a not.
So here is going to be
the electronic energy
as a function of x.
And here is x.
And all right.
So as x goes to 0,
means the nuclei
are going on top of each other.
That's the place where the wave
function is not all that great.
And that's not so good.
It turns out that here
you get minus 3 Rydbergs.
Remember, the Rydberg was
e squared over 2 a not.
And it's about 13.6 ev.
It's just the ground state
energy of the hydrogen.
You do get that the energy due
to the electronic configuration
is negative and it
goes to this value.
And then it starts to grow
quadratically and goes up.
And I want to know, in
your opinion, what's
going to be the next asymptote?
So what is it going to
asymptote as x goes to infinity?
Let let's make the analogy.
The right answer is it
actually stops here.
And you'll remember this problem
that you've solved many times,
probably.
If you have a--
suppose a square well.
You have a wave function
that is like that.
Now, if you have two
square well-- and it
has a ground state energy.
If you have two square
wells like that and you ask,
what is the ground state energy?
The ground state energy is
roughly equal to the ground
state energy for a single
square well because what happens
is that the wave function
goes like that and then like--
well, actually, like that.
So yes, the wave function
spends equal time.
But it's the same
energy as if there
would be a single square well.
So here it is.
The protons are very far away in
the symmetric state, the ground
state.
The electron is half the times
here, half the times there.
But the energy is
the same energy
as if it would be in either one.
So this is an intuition that
you may have from 804 or 805.
So here it is.
That's what it does.
That's good.
In fact, if you ride the
ee of x over Rydbergs,
it behaves here
like minus 3 plus x
squared plus dot, dot, dot.
So it starts growing
and then asymptotes
with an exponential there.
OK, but what did we say was the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation
was the idea that then you have
dynamics of the nuclei based
on--
so Born-Oppenheimer tells
you that the Hamiltonian
for the nuclear degrees
of freedom is given by h.
This h effective is
capital P over 2m squared
plus the nuclear
nuclear potential,
plus this electronic energy.
So this electronic energy
we already calculated.
The nuclear nuclear
potential, in this case,
is the proton proton potential,
v m n is e squared over r.
It is repulsive.
You see, this-- if you wanted to
minimize the electronic energy,
you still don't get anything.
You get a system that
collapses to zero.
That's certainly
not the molecule.
But this n n is this, so we can
write it as e squared over 2a0
and then put a 2 over
r over a 0 to get
all these numbers nicely.
So the nvv is a
Rydberg times 2 over x.
So in terms of x there,
vnn is a 2 over x--
oops-- a 2 over x
potential like that.
So now you have the possibility
of getting a stable grounding,
so the potential
for the nucleons.
So the total potential
for the nucleons
is the sum of these
two potentials.
And how does it look?
Well, some of the
two potential--
so ee of x plus vnn of x.
Let's divide by Rydberg
as a function of x, goes--
here is minus 1.
And it goes more or less like--
OK.
Let me try to get this right.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
OK.
It goes up here, down,
crosses the minus 1 line,
and moves to a minimum here.
And then it goes like that.
Pretty much it's
something like that.
It's a rather little
quadratic minimum.
It's rather flat.
And these are the
numbers you care for.
This is the minimum.
Maybe it doesn't look like
that in my graph too well.
But it's a very flat minimum.
And r over a0 at the
minimum is, in fact, 2.49.
And e over Rydberg at the
minimum is minus 1.297.
Those are results.
Now, you have a potential.
You could calculate
the quadratic term
around the potential.
And then you get an approximate
oscillation Hamiltonian
that those would be
the nuclear vibrations.
You could calculate
the frequency
of the nuclear
vibrations and the energy
of the nuclear vibration.
It's a very simple
but nice model.
You can calculate everything
pretty much about this molecule
and compare with experiments.
So how does it do the
comparison with experiment?
It does OK.
It doesn't do very well.
So let me tell you
what's happening.
So again, we do get this system.
Happily, the minimum
was below minus 1.
The minus 1 was the situation
in which you have a hydrogen
atom and a free proton.
So there is a bound state energy
but the bounds state energy
is not conceptually right to
think of it as this big energy.
It's just this little
part here in which
this is the extra
binding that you
can have when you bring a proton
near to the hydrogen atom.
So this extra part--
so the bound state energy--
I'll write a couple of
words here and we'll stop.
The bound state energy is E.
This E that we determined here
at the minimum is
minus 1 Rydberg
minus 0.1297 Rydbergs which is
minus 1 Rydberg minus 1.76 ev.
So this is what you would
call the bound state
energy of this system because
it's the least energy you need
to start to dissociate it--
not to dissociate it completely,
but to start to dissociate it.
1.76.
True value is 2.8
ev, so not great,
but sort of order of magnitude.
Another thing that
you can ask is,
what is the separation between
the nuclei in this ion?
How far away are they?
And this gives a prediction
that it's about 2.49 a0.
So separation is r equal
2.49 a0, which is 2.49 times
0.529 angstroms.
It's about 1.32 angstroms.
And through value's 2.8.
Experimental value, the
value of r, our experiment
is not that far.
It's 106 angstroms.
So it's 20% there, 25% there.
But it gives you a way to
think about this system.
You get all the physics.
You understand the physics.
The Born-Oppenheimer
physics is that the electron
energy in the fixed lattice is
a potential term for the nuclei.
Added to the nucleus
nucleus repulsion
gives you the total potential
term for the nuclear degrees
of freedom.
You can find the
stable situation.
And if you want to do quantum
mechanics and vibrations
of the nuclei, well, do
the harmonic oscillator
associated with this thing.
The nice thing is
you can complicate
these wave functions
a little and get
better and better answers.
And it's fun.
It's things that can
be done numerically.
And you have a
remarkably powerful tool
to understand these things.
So with this, we'll
close our whole chapter
in adiabatic physics.
And next time, we will
begin with scattering.